[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whether but we want
and today we have Gina
yep Oh neat that I don't call her Gina
fourteen anymore oh and then your bun is
leaving to the left but first this is
all fake hair so just okay God they get
to our sponsor love book love book
allows you to create a custom design
book for any occasion telling someone
why they are special has never been this
easy and fun you can customize your book
as much or as little as you like love
books help customers express the
sentiments that they may be difficult to
say out loud especially all the Asian
dudes out there users can create
characters that look just like
themselves and the recipient down to the
outfits and accessories try a unique
gift this year for Christmas Valentine's
Day anniversaries birthdays or just
because for about the cost of flower
delivery you can have a premium gift
that will last for years not just a few
days look book now offers a membership
program as well you'll receive a free
book when you sign them 50% off any
additional books unlimited free digital
books and discounts and gift wrap and
thanks so visit love book online.com
slash off the record to receive a
special 20% discount only for our
listeners again that's love book
online.com off the record slash off the
record to receive a special 20% discount
click in the description box below for
the link and get you 20% discount very
cool very spec very wonderful good dude
let me talk about this religious you met
a religious [ __ ] it looks it looks like
a muppet look at me in jail she's like
the rich mission I'm like the the wanna
be rich [ __ ] I look like a crackhead
she looks like she [ __ ] kill them up
and skinned it for the jackets
this is true yeah you look good you look
like you know what it is you both look
like New York streetwalker Joe's gonna
come in and wrap it up that's like a Law
& Order SVU and they go interviewed a
hooker yeah yeah no worried they're like
baby what I'm just missing the bubble
let me take my fake bond out yeah and
then like we need info what's gonna cost
you what about that religious [ __ ]
so okay so what's in a mall this past
weekend all right who goes to the mall I
love moles I'm such a little mall rat
dude I've been since like middle school
which one's your favorite
I think I said I need a like it's so
close good about wood is [ __ ] so
Chinese now there's a teen implantation
you know how long have you been there
yeah she almost guy being implants you
like that so sure you know Chinese when
you see like little old ladies just like
walk around the mall in the middle of
the [ __ ] night
damn this place that's one Chinese then
there's a whole Chinese wing to it
Macy's whatever and then there's a whole
like side where there's no English words
and it's just all time you mean where
the hot pot area is I don't know what
area that is business for special
everyone's peeing cuz I've ever taken
eyes except for his baby photos like he
was literally like an Indian and that's
where we would go I would go every three
months
go back recently yeah have been sold I
got like it's on tape
from where a cheesecake fountain gotetsu
dude Japanese oh that place is is that
on the American side of the Sargent
iPhones right next to me here that
that's the American Din Tai Fung yeah
the other side the outdoor there's an
outdoor side Oh the promenade the
promenade that's the Chinese side that
yeah those were all the stores where I
would not again and I was like like
China Airlines airplane yeah preceded
their story um so wait I was at the mall
of my friend and we were parking right
and then there was a car waiting for a
car here and we were waiting for this
one here this one was signaling for this
side we were selling for this side but
she realized that ours was going faster
she started singling for this side and
we're like what the [ __ ] do you think
you're doing and I was with my
whose autry like two shots in because
we're degenerates right and she started
signaling and then the card left and she
turned in so my friend leans over and
just lays on the horse starts screaming
and then so here's the thing my friend's
a lawyer so he's like you're drinking it
driving friend is also a lawyer said he
leaned on the horn didn't yell would be
the best ones to do that because they
could play get out of it yeah right so
so he reaches over and he leans on the
horn and just screaming so I put the car
in park he's like you know he gets out
of the car takes his jacket off goes it
in the [ __ ] car and he goes in not
centered or that was our spot and then
okay so you imagine like the most caring
of all Karen's in the [ __ ] world
white middle-aged she has a stupid-ass
little [ __ ] puppy right
I have an aunt named Karen who looks
like that and then she's like I was
waiting for this he said no you were
singling for that this one I realized
that I should have become a lawyer
because if I were a lawyer I would be
like I would not know how to act like
I'm picking fights with everyone right
so as you know all the rules of yeah
yeah exactly right you could dance
around all those things exactly so he
was like she was like we were waiting
for this one you're waiting for that one
she has a dash cam ever dash cam oh my
god but wait both you guys I passed yeah
I do I have a dash cam he said she has
it that me do you use it to vlog pointed
outwards right so you have to run hood
and be like thank you for reminding me
because I think if I ever get into a
road rage street fight yeah I'm gonna
look on the windshield first break it
off and then beat the [ __ ] out very
smart break often yeah I'm also a lot
braver with the dash cam because now I'm
like hit me I want you to hit me like if
there's a [ __ ] like Bentley in front
of me like [ __ ] hit me please like
I'm begging you anyhow
so she like knows way too bubbly then he
goes or she goes but I was here first
because she thought if she's here first
she gets first pick of whatever
yeah like Loreen [ __ ] oh can take
that word wait if you're first you
should get first big there's
right-of-way in the cars right so she
you eat like just cuz I bet your signal
I thought the way it works is if you
signal for the direction that there
you're communicating like I'm going for
this one and then none of us got it
here's my signal I'm going for this
right yeah if it's if you got I life if
you got an island of Understanding yeah
so he's not first-come first-serve I
thought squishy oh no she's white never
mind well some people have the [ __ ]
most tinted as windows I don't even know
what they're doing in there she wasn't a
shitty it like she was on a silver BMW
with a pole dent in the back so he knows
[ __ ] can't drive she kept up into that
month so she finally like she's like
fine if she tries to back up without
looking at nearly rear end of the car
that's coming through and so this car
that's coming through it's like this
Mexican guy and he's he starts pulling I
know I am being Mexican he was very
Mexican and knows his [ __ ] because he
pulled out his phone right and he
automatically thought my friend was the
main like because he was a guy and you
know he does I got this all on camera I
want to call the cops and my friends a
lawyer he stands up he goes
call the [ __ ] cops then they say I
got this all on camera and I have I have
your your license plate and he points
out of my car and I scream out what
license plate I haven't put plates on my
car in like two years I have no place
look I just wanna say you're all trans
people does the dark conversation still
describe but i'ma try it's about the
principle yeah no I get it but even your
lawyer guy he's [ __ ] drafted to call
the cops so many times in so many
shopping malls you look at the jacket
take it offered it to you what the
difference is I'm a trash person with a
lawyer
better call Saul right there he's like I
got your license plate I'm like what
license plate what are you look for
County Honda dumbass even so my friend
gets back and then so no and then she
gets brave again she pulls into the
parking spot went well nevermind I got
backup now [ __ ] Hector's my ho man
yeah her dogs yapping and then my friend
goes okay I hope you realize I know
where you parked and she goes and he
gets back in the car and we drove off
past the Mexican guy an American guys
like hmm
and then so later on I go into the mall
and I don't to the mall and I guess what
stupid dumb [ __ ] I see with the little
puppy dog holding a prayer circle in the
middle of food court [ __ ] carrying
yeah a prayer circle they would just
stand there just praying in the middle
of a [ __ ] food court next to the
appendix she's taking God that she did
get in trouble this she's praying to get
all the minorities out of there lays low
letting me thirty years ago when there
was no chinks here crazy [ __ ] crazy
that's funny that's crazy I mean y'all
could have just drove past and found
another parking space like the most
international drama I've heard argue
like what a melting pot of [ __ ]
losers I didn't really do anything you
just kind of came out right I didn't
yeah anything in that wall altercations
all I yelled was would license plate you
got dragged into a mess
well it's fine though because it's like
well when you have a dash cam and you
have a lawyer with you you get really
brave like [ __ ] whatever happens
happens that's true that's like you pick
a bar fight with Superman yeah yeah well
if he was a patent lawyer I wouldn't be
so brave like what is your specialty I'm
a [ __ ] lawyer what do you do I help
people with their copyrights and
trademarks and inventions and after I
keep this is God's will in your car [ __ ]
that's a great way if you get pulled
over too it's like oh I don't want to
step out of the car my cousin's a lawyer
Oh your cousin's a lawyer okay they
changed their [ __ ] act like that and
I [ __ ] got away with so many Judy buy
that [ __ ] hell yeah was [ __ ] bricks
I had a [ __ ] half a pound of weed in
my [ __ ] jacket I'm innocent officer
and my cousin who's a lawyer says that
have to get out of the car oh dude it's
even better at my uncle was a sheriff
and he he had a those license plates as
basically says that you're a sheriff so
he would go like 130 pounds like former
law enforcement like she like and so
they could just get away with well no
it's just it's the one of those license
plate wrap things I'm saying like I'd
rather be skiing but a lot of people do
that
so and then a lot of people donate to
these certain cop charities and then
they put that bumper sticker yeah
they're [ __ ] good as gold more though
because you're aging you're not what you
do if you're black you really gotta fill
out have you seen where the bumper has
like 10 stickers of the police donation
just in case you don't [ __ ] see it's
pretty crazy
that's kind of a parody at that point
then the cops like come on man is this
real there are people out there that do
that though oh yeah yeah that's
fascinating
hyrum anyone who like my aunts like this
she's like she married a sheriff and now
her life is just all about sheriff life
like hashtag sheriff wife it's like
military wives
yeah yeah that's her she's such a pain
in the ass like depend upon a missus is
well my that's what they're called they
just sit there and be like my husband's
this elite to me because my husband's
high-ranking well my husband my husband
yeah who the [ __ ] are you yeah my
brother almost got married to a chick
who already started buying like like um
[ __ ] Air Force white sweaters and
[ __ ] and like first of all Air Force
wife you know military [ __ ] come on
nobody's like damn that guy's in the Air
Force
oh [ __ ] it's all so funny when like the
wife doesn't have their own identity so
I remember when your sister was dating
the dude me and him were justified
cracking military jokes and then she
would be like oh my god I like you've
never capped outside in the dirt like
what are you laughing at right to that
but their identity becomes theirs oh
yeah I just becomes like it's funny
thing yeah and then she's like I'm
really called it 70 degrees
badass military women yeah I heard
that's what they do at the base this job
when your husband's deployed we have to
keep this family together
that's that part's our bullet my dick is
harder than that
good job Karen you're at home sting like
cheating on your husband good job like a
lot of them like the cheat huh huh yeah
do you like it it's a sport yeah the
military sport right it's a thing it's
definitely thing mm-hmm
I know some military kids that grew up
on base and then they say the same thing
we're like that's all their moms and
stuff dudes they just go to these like
[ __ ] dinners with other military moms
and all they do is talk about their
husbands ranks and how much money
they're got yeah imagine not having a
personality I mean it kind of feels like
a jail don't you think like you're on
base in a different country it's like
little America and you have no [ __ ]
thing to do and you get to hang out with
other ladies who are just trapped it's
like if you like being taken care of
yeah that's like the best like if you're
a female that doesn't really want to
work and you just want to depend on the
dude your hospitals there well that's
true everything said everything is the
ARBs gonna set in and then yeah you're
just like [ __ ] I can't get out of here
what the [ __ ] did you guys ever know
military kids growing up though not
growing up okay so I think about my
mother growing up and like she did not
teach us how to fold clothes like
military right and I met my friend Zach
who was a military kid like his dad was
[ __ ] Marines used to work at the
Pentagon and [ __ ] that kid folded his
clothes so well that he can he could
stack like a thousand shirts in his
drawer because they're like that's like
this so that how much does that help as
a mom to have all your kids able to
[ __ ] fold [ __ ] paper-thin yeah pretty
sick benefits to being diligent don't
work really well at retail stores see
yeah and you go to Abercrombie & Fitch
and just [ __ ] hire on the spot dude
Abercrombie employs to come up to you
like yeah slow down
hey here to have a cuppa we don't do as
many shirts I don't know an hour ever
come I can still smell that store me too
yeah where would you set it does this
smell good or not it smell good
oh [ __ ] I just saw dark and it smells
good too douche bags look Oh
douche bag man cuz they walk in there I
liked it I liked it your qualities Pro
the inside is really constant it never
made me want to shop in there made me
want to sleep yeah I'm like nothing
nothing here is for me it's darkest [ __ ]
yeah I don't know why it's so dark right
you can't even see the clothes yeah grab
the clothes find a light and then should
go oh yeah
cramped in because they have like 16
plants in each aisle - it makes no sense
the clothes sizes are like extra extra
small but then if there's like large
true makes you feel buff though as a guy
like extra-large like it's tight as [ __ ]
so Jack no I just tried it on cause it's
kind of uh I wore one I just I had one
thing because I went in and I checked it
I was like oh I liked it it was just
like a UH like a distressed college
shirt I'm sure I'm sure that shirt had
some troubles it looked like it was a
homeless shirt you pop the collar no
like two shirts and they pop both
callers like what the [ __ ] is going on
used to I got a good last week and then
like their hair was all spiked up last
time you guys went to like the Beverly
Center this [ __ ] still exists
is fallen from grace - like that place
needs to be bougie and now this is gross
- pretty girl roast now but that whole
outlying area has plenty of this doosh
doosh factor dish factor 20 I like going
to the Glendale mall in that area the
Mara Conda yeah I do when I used to work
at the Glendale area like man there was
just so much
Armenians Armenians and most of it
what's that damn shirt they wear this
all bedazzled and [ __ ]
Oh ed hardy and Marty you're like
affliction yeah in Christian Audigier
the sequins shirts yeah dragons yeah
cologne what you're describing there
mm-hmm I hear a guy very loudly talking
on the cell phone to somebody rule yeah
he's very intense very intense I used to
work at the Cheesecake Factory there I
was a hostess I was like one of my first
jobs ever at the medically uh-huh yeah
that was like my favorite jobs actually
and I was just always like I would tell
them like oh the waste 30 minutes
they'll come back in five minutes I've
been waiting for an hour and I like my
manager is really nice to me so I would
be like a douche bag and I was just like
flip my monitor around like you were
here for five minutes and I have you
here for 30 minutes and they would try
to - I've been trying to bribe me once
like oh I'll give you guys 20 bucks each
should we go on Mother's Day like you're
a bounce
oh yeah well that's the first time at
that cheesecake my boss telling me when
we went to go eat there maybe like a
month or two ago that was the first time
I actually saw someone bribed someone
not in a movie I'm like like this old
man right he's probably like 60 or 70
and he goes he comes up to any laws uh
can I get seated please in the late I'll
like do you have a reservation and he
goes yeah he goes like this with a $20
bill and I'm like oh are you [ __ ]
serious like he was like I'll give you
guys age 20 bucks I'm like yeah want me
if you can go to the bank and go or he's
like I gotta go to the bank get money he
comes back he goes um the big would only
let me take out $10 and there was three
broke-ass [ __ ] or anything
I'm sorry I'm not gonna do it for like
three bucks each do you know thank you
thank you the table you sit there eat
drink water and [ __ ] eat the bread
someone did that once
thank you man and we couldn't charge
them chocolate breads hella bomb I love
that bread it's just brown bread it's
not chocolate can you taste things when
you eat that wait is it the one with the
oats on it he's looking I worked there
for like a year and a half and I still
love the food there in the bread I used
to sneak that [ __ ] when I was just
eating like it at the front desk I
recently took myself on a solo date and
I ate there you know solo date huh yeah
I liked it no because I went there to go
charge my car cuz I have a super charger
and then I did some shopping and I was
like I'm hungry and then I did also
eating by yourself that sounds better
you realize that you branded it like I
got dressed up I put on my make a table
for one talk to myself always on a solo
date then
[Music]
[Music]